who is there hello hi who are you I'm
John John lovely I'm where you from John
I live in London originally from
Northern own ordinary just outside
Belfast in Northern bangers lovely
banger it's not the seaside resort
lovely yes yes bringing it here down I
do what do you do here I try to make it
easier for people with disabilities to
bank - what - bang
my career guidance officer
never suggested that to me
[Laughter]
I can't wait we're here story now off
you go sir so I got up one morning as
usual getting myself ready to go to work
and from from getting I'd abandoned the
20 feet or so to get to the bathroom
I was excruciatingly peon around the the
rectal region yeah dr. Clarkson's very
concerned
and I think if she could have ee art I I
did go to the doctors got seen
straightaway and he says right can you
remove your trousers and underwear and
lie down and think happy thoughts so he
rummaged about and he then yeah he asked
me a question do you like asparagus and
pulled out asparagus tip from my illness
bizarrely I had not eaten asparagus for
months
[Applause]
answers on a postcard
the hell was that about
yes to get in and then get out cuz
they're so weird at the top on that I
don't into his house an insert surely
that I don't understand
okay so Amir tried to surprise my
beautiful wife Alma Alma yeah see she
actually in the audience tonight Oh
where's Alma you sure know your
beautiful wife Alma's still here off you
go Valerie it was a nice surprise
yes of course okay she's pregnant Oh our
first baby oh we don't know yet the
gender of the baby because I really want
wait until the baby's born of course
Larry but she really want to know as
soon as possible
oh yes so the doctor wrote this piece of
paper the gender of the baby and I say
to her we will open in a special
occasion so because she loves you and
your show I believe that tonight is the
best may I open yes
[Applause]
okay Gary back
here we go so Alma dama you ready it'll
be a boy or a girl you're calling it
Wayne here we go here we go
the babies is a girl
sir okay the hopes of a nation around
you Paul yes and were you from I'm from
Colchester Essex gorgeous on Essex and
what do you do there well I don't work
in Colchester working Thompson but I
work in retail
was in the detail
from is the bridge of the Starship
Enterprise
see he doesn't sort of William Shatner
thing going on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this story I was working on what was a
fairly short construction job at the
local zoo oh and John Picard is talking
on a fairly hazy morning I was holding
up a steel which didn't manage to keep
hold of and it slipped through my
fingers and as it did it went across the
road that was into the ring-tailed lemur
enclosure but actually snapped through
the electric fence and Jamie in the
corner of the in the corner of the the
pit that I was working in and actually
the electric fence was on quite high and
where I'd got jammed it actually come up
between my legs and I'd actually got an
electric shock for a couple of minutes
before he moved whereby were the
ring-tailed lemurs that actually decided
to escape
[Applause]
off you go with historic so this takes
place in 1977 which was the year of the
queen silver jubilee so would you
believe I must get a pen Tony and and we
were having a street party in a little
closer in West in West Ealing yes yes
and a few months before this Phil
Collins had moved into the place this
couldn't be more 1977 it was the time
when Genesis were at the height of their
fame we were all very excited my mother
was on the committee and she was
collecting money for the streetcars oh
she's great she's great yes she got to
Phil Collins's door and knocked on the
door and he answered and she explained
what she was doing and he gave her some
money and then he said to her what do
you do for music because if you like I
could bring the boys round and she said
no that's okay thinks we've got a disco
[Applause]
okay so I was out for a run with my
friend dunk and we were running past
there and don't really needed to go for
a poo that's why you've never been to
New Zealand blocking was a means and a
woman's and we ran out to the men's and
he was busting he really needed to get
this thing out of him the means was
closed so at this stage he didn't even
care so he went over to the woman's
toilets and that was close as well so
he's frantically looking around where
can I go we can I go so he ran over to
this bush and crouched down behind this
bush and he went in about 30 seconds
later I saw this a big German Shepherd
came bounding over and don't pull his
pants up jogged off and then this and
then about 20 seconds later the owner of
the German Shepherd came over and she's
like oh boy
[Applause]
one more one more here we go here we go
hello hi oh hi what's your name my name
is Sebastian Sebastian yeah where you
from I'm from Newcastle Newcastle okay
do you live there or here I live in
Newcastle yeah okay off you go with joy
Sebastian
well many moons ago were actually at his
school in Newcastle and there was a
disco coming up it was a really popular
go to school
he's just like a scenario that all that
you know all the guys after I sort of
like waited to the last moment last
couple of days
and asked a girl was this popular girl
in question if she liked to go with me
she said yes this was literally I think
the day before the disco lo and behold
the turns out that she was actually
gonna go with somebody else and that
other person was actually charlie
Sebastian Olivia
[Applause]
Rachel gold the very same yep see know
who it is did you end up marrying Rachel
gold no yeah no have a sword with you to
you you could you could add revenge if
you want to do you want I'm originally
from Suffolk oh it's a Suffolk massif is
he mentioned in the song probably yeah
know what school did you go to um so I
went to Brandes then so yeah well I with
the from primary school okay did we know
each other yeah
[Applause]
James hello yeah James yes me that's the
one what the [__] wait up and now you're
talking to him honestly he's right oh my
god can we not flip them and just get
them out of here do you have a story or
do you boy yeah I did but it's leaves
let it be about okay sorry then we'll
flip you and then okay cool yeah yeah
when we were younger ed used to come
round to my house and yell at you saying
we used to be quite good mates and I
remember one time one time he's come
around 40 and I've forgotten to tell mum
who's a vegetarian at that point anyway
and so mum cooked
I think the sausage and mash 40 and Ed
said you know after the meal these are
the best sausages I've ever tasted you
know where did you get them from a mum
had to lie because she had no clue
sorry first time I ever had me and also
the first time I ever watch The Simpsons
episode was around you and we can be
reunited backstage
I feel like Cilla black on surprise
surprise
[Applause]
Renda me have a seat have a seat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
[Music]